thanks to fabulous for helping support
this episode
hey crazies capacitors make no sense
they're tiny physical gaps in a circuit
they shouldn't even work
but they do work somehow
in fact if we analyze capacitors on a
deep level we see they're almost
breathing energy
[Music]
before we start discussing abstract
things like energy i want to make sure
we understand the tangible stuff first
capacitors come in a wide variety of
shapes and sizes and are made from a
wide variety of materials
but all of them are designed to make use
of a gap in a wire
the most basic design for a capacitor is
two metal plates separated by an air gap
in practice though the gap is usually
filled with a solid material called a
dielectric
wouldn't that close the gap though
actually no it's still a gap because
dielectrics are insulators then why even
include them a few reasons
first the metal plates are going to
build up opposite electric charges
opposite charges tend to attract the
dielectric holds the plates apart that
means we can put the plates closer
together if we want to
second anything can become a conductor
with enough voltage including air
dielectrics tend to be better insulators
than air so they help prevent sparks and
third the third reason comes down to how
capacitors work
the simplest circuit looks something
like this a battery a light bulb and a
couple of wires if they're connected to
form a closed loop then charges have a
place to go
that flow is seen as an electric current
through the circuit
the charge must flow
but if there's a gap charges don't have
a place to go which means there isn't a
current
right
well not so fast
we might like our physical rules to be
simple but as john green would say the
truth resists simplicity whether or not
a gap stops an electric current depends
on the size of the gap
we're all pretty sure a big open switch
would prevent it but the distance
between atoms and a wire is also
technically a gap
no one ever worries about those tiny
gaps preventing a current
the gap in a well-designed capacitor is
on the order of a micrometer give or
take
that's a thousand times bigger than
atomic spacing but a thousand times
smaller than an open switch it's in that
vague gray area in between
it is a big enough gap to break the
circuit but not immediately
most of our instincts about electric
circuits are based on how they work once
they've settled into something we call
the steady state in that state the
capacitor is definitely a break in the
circuit
at least when the circuit is dc like all
our examples so far in this video but
there's a short time at the beginning
when you first turn on the circuit when
its behavior won't necessarily match our
intuitions that's the transient state of
the circuit
this is the state where the capacitor
shines
i mean metaphorically not literally if
your capacitor is literally shining
you're having a bad day
anyway the transient state of the
circuit doesn't usually last very long
if all you've got is a light bulb and a
battery it only lasts a tiny fraction of
a second fast fast but a capacitor could
extend that time dramatically the
transient state could easily last a few
seconds
it's still a gap though isn't it yeah
and that's the whole point
imagine you've got a battery a capacitor
a few wires and a switch to turn things
on and off the battery is fully
energized so there's a voltage between
the two ends
voltage is related to energy so we're
starting to get a little abstract here
just remember that an energy difference
or a gradient is what allows stuff to
happen all hand ingredients
when a battery has a voltage that just
means it can do stuff given the
opportunity that's all that matters
right now
with the switch open that voltage
doesn't have an opportunity to do
anything when we flip it closed
everything changes but not right away
at first there's no voltage across the
capacitor
wait that can't be right voltage is what
allows circuit stuff to happen if
there's no voltage across the capacitor
then nothing should happen inside the
capacitor
hold on
[Music]
this can't be right what am i doing
wrong
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
got it
okay i am right but there's a subtle
nuance i need to explain
conservation of energy dictates that
whatever the battery puts in the rest of
the circuit takes out
conservation of energy shall not be
violent
in a circuit we account for that with
voltage
but the voltage drop across the
capacitor is not necessarily equal to
the voltage added by the battery
it's very common to assume these wires
have exactly zero resistance as electro
boom would say they are magic wires in
reality though they're not zero
resistance
no material is exactly zero resistance
not even superconductors don't at me
we only ignore wire resistance when
there are larger sources of resistance
when there aren't larger sources we have
to include the wire resistance there's
no choice which means there are actually
two places voltage can drop across the
capacitor or across the wires
when we first flip the switch closed
there's no charge build up on the plates
so this is zero
there is a voltage applied to the
capacitor but all the voltage is dropped
across the wires
over time though charge builds up and
the capacitor takes over
once it completely takes over the
circuit is broken
essentially the capacitor has its own
voltage now that perfectly cancels the
driving voltage from the battery with no
overall energy gradient nothing can
happen the electric current stops
it behaves exactly how you'd expect a
gap to behave it has reached steady
state
the entire charging process before that
was the transient state with these low
resistance wires it only lasted a few
micro seconds fast fast but if we put a
larger resistor in there it could easily
last milliseconds or even whole seconds
except it wouldn't have charged at all
if there wasn't an electric current
right correct how is there an electric
current across an insulating gap oh it
doesn't but we get a current on either
side of the gap anyway
if it helps you can imagine there's a
current in there even though there isn't
we've been avoiding talking about fields
so far but we can't anymore the behavior
of electric charge is inherently linked
to the behavior of the electromagnetic
field
this field usually carries a value of
zero but that all changes when electric
charges are around
you get a non-zero electric field by
default but you get a non-zero magnetic
field if the charges move around
these two fields are often considered
one thing the electromagnetic field
it surrounds us and penetrates us but it
doesn't really bind the galaxy together
it is super important for circuits
though
for example if there's a changing
electric field across the gap in a
capacitor it'll behave a lot like an
electric current the resemblance is so
uncanny that we refer to that changing
field as a displacement current
but to understand how this works the
water analogy might be helpful
a battery is kind of like a water pump
it's not the source of the water it's
the reason the water moves
a capacitor would be like a chamber with
a rubber diaphragm in the middle
water can't pass through it but the
diaphragm is flexible if the pump is on
it's going to push water into the
diaphragm as the diaphragm deforms it
pushes water on the other side
even though the water can't pass through
the diaphragm it still moves on both
sides
at least until the diaphragm is against
the wall of the chamber that's when the
flow stops
a similar thing happens inside a
capacitor
as electric charge builds up on the
positive plate an electric field grows
inside the gap
that field pushes charge on the other
plate causing a current on the other
side of the capacitor even though no
charge actually jumps the gap it still
flows on both sides
now this visual may be fairly accurate
but it isn't always necessary it's a lot
easier to step up a level of abstraction
instead of imagining a changing electric
field inside the gap why don't we just
imagine an electric current in there
mathematically that's pretty easy to do
this stuff in ampere's law just becomes
a secondary current the displacement
current we simply swap the field out for
an imaginary current and move on if all
you care about is the flow of charge
that's plenty good enough if you care
about where the energy is well that's
where the field matters
most of the time it doesn't matter how
energy moves in a circuit all that
matters is that it starts at some source
like a battery and gets to where you
want it to go
that's why what i'm about to tell you
doesn't usually get taught in electrical
engineering courses but i'm a
theoretical physicist
physiophysicist physicist i'm a
physicist
but i'm a theoretical physicist not an
engineer so practical spectacle let's go
for the deeper understanding
we like to think a battery provides some
energy to a charged particle then that
particle carries the energy around to
wherever it's needed
energy is provided to charges over and
over again until the battery runs out of
energy or the bulb is turned off
it's a nice simple visual and it might
be fine for an electrical engineer but
fundamentally it's wrong
the energy isn't provided to the
particle at all
yes there are positive particles flowing
around there is an electric current it's
just that the energy in this electric
current isn't what the circuit uses to
do its thing
the particles certainly have kinetic
energy but that kinetic energy isn't
what the circuit uses those charges
don't slow down
once they settle into a steady flow
that's their speed all the way around
the current at different spots in a
circuit is determined by how many
charges are there not their speed
the energy the circuit uses to do
whatever it does is carried by the
fields around the circuit when we're
done here you can check out this video
from a few years ago if you want a full
explanation but here's the quickie
version
the flow of energy in the
electromagnetic field is described by
the pointing vector as you can see the
electric field and the magnetic field
are both involved
you need both or there's no energy flow
this equation tells us two important
bits of information
one the energy flowing through a
specific point is proportional to the
field strengths at that point
and two the direction of that flow is
perpendicular to both fields
in the simple battery light bulb circuit
that means the energy flows kind of like
this
it comes out of the battery into the
surrounding field and then flows through
the field to its destination what's that
look like for a capacitor i'm so glad
you asked
it looks like this
for real for real allow me to explain
earlier we saw what the electric field
looks like inside a capacitor
but here's the magnetic field
it wraps around any current in the
circuit including the displacement
current in the gap
remember that displacement current is
still a useful abstraction
the pointing vector says the flow of
energy is always perpendicular to both
fields that means it points into the gap
from outside as the plates charge up
energy flows into the capacitor like
this
once it's fully charged the current
stops which means no more magnetic field
which means no more pointing vector
which means no more energy flow the
capacitor is holding all the energy it
can at this moment
if the current is alternating the charge
discharge cycle will repeat
it almost looks like the capacitor is
breathing
[Music]
capacitors are so cool
they're a device designed to use a gap
in a circuit
air gap capacitors do exist but they're
usually filled with some kind of solid
insulator as the plates charge up an
electric field grows inside that behaves
a lot like an electric current that
current causes a magnetic field to form
and ultimately allows energy to flow
mind you energy is also kind of an
abstraction
that means energy flowing inside fields
is an abstraction inside of another
abstraction
but it's really beautiful to look at
isn't it
so what do you think of capacitors now
please share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to all my
patreon patrons and youtube members for
making all this possible don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy
thanks again to fabulous the number one
self-care app to help you build better
habits and achieve your goals
do you have any good habits you want to
start or bad habits you want to stop
fabulous can help with that
self-improvement mental health physical
health mindfulness
really whatever habit you're looking for
it can be 100 personalized for you and
your needs
maybe you want to drink more water or
start doing stretches every morning
maybe you just want to set some time
aside for reading or meditation
my wife has been using it for exercise
and food related habits
fabulous does track your habits but it's
more than just a habit tracker it's
actually based on studies done in
behavioral science
if you want or need a self-guided
experience that's fine if socializing
with other motivated people helps you
there are features for that too
there's even a built-in digital coach to
keep you motivated every day if you're
interested go to the link in the
description below
the first hundred people to click the
link will get 25 percent off a fabulous
premium subscription it'll also let
fabulous know you heard about them for
me which helps out the channel
many of you were wondering what exactly
negative roughness means i avoided the
negative states on purpose because they
don't really matter unless there's
interference without interference they
behave just like their positive
counterparts anyway thanks for watching